Trascrizione: Alessia Giorgiutti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno.
Oggi vorrei parlarvi di tre cose.
Tre cose che ci sono generalmente a cuore:
della felicità, del successo, e del tempo.
Mi sono spesso chiesto:
"Ma bisogna avere successo
per essere felici,
o essere felici è una condizione
necessaria per avere successo?"
Beh, da piccolo
era tutto abbastanza chiaro:
io, come tutti quelli
della mia generazione,
siamo cresciuti con una frase
che ci sentivamo spesso ripetere:
"Prima il dovere e poi il piacere".
Non ci piaceva - a me faceva sbuffare;
però in qualche modo ci ha aiutato
a crescere più o meno diligentemente.
Poi, con l'arrivare
delle prime responsabilità,
ho inizialmente rincorso
il mito del "work-life balance".
Ossia ho cercato
di trovare il giusto equilibrio
tra il tempo destinato al lavoro
e quello destinato alla vita privata.
Ma poi il mondo è diventato
improvvisamente iper-connesso,
e io mi sono trovato impreparato
nel gestire la work-life integration:
in altre parole,
ho finito per perdere i confini
tra le pareti domestiche
e quelle dell'ufficio.
E quindi, connesso 24 ore al giorno,
sette giorni su sette,
sfinito fisicamente e mentalmente,
ho capito che rincorrere tutto e tutti
non significa necessariamente
raggiungere dei risultati eccellenti,
né tantomeno essere felici.
È la innata cultura umana
che ci porta a pensare
che per avere successo
bisogna fare sempre di più.
Io penso invece che,
soprattutto oggi, bisogna fare di meno.
Come? Scegliendo.
Scegliendo come, e a chi,
dedicare la nostra risorsa
più preziosa: il nostro tempo.
Il tempo è una vera
materia prima pregiata:
non si trova in natura,
ci viene donata ogni giorno.
Si potrebbe dire
che ne abbiamo in abbondanza,
e proprio questa abbondanza
non ci fa percepire
tutta la bellezza del dono.
Per questo ci troviamo spesso
a trascorrere le nostre giornate
rincorrendo affannosamente:
arriviamo la sera stanchi
con questo senso di affanno
che prevale sulla sensazione
di avere contribuito
piacevolmente a qualcosa.
A volte facciamo le ultime cose dopo cena,
prima di andare a dormire;
altre volte mettiamo la sveglia
un'ora prima la mattina -
non dite che non l'avete mai fatto.
Ma tornando alla necessità
di scegliere e fare meno,
se provassimo a pensare
a quanto tempo, in una giornata,
impieghiamo nel prendere decisioni,
scopriremo che questo
ne occupa la quasi totalità.
Ogni giorno, infatti, decidiamo:
a che ora svegliarci;
a che ora alzarci;
come vestirci; dove andare:
noi continuamente decidiamo dove guardare.
Ma avete mai provato a pensare
quanto tempo, noi, dedichiamo ogni giorno
nello scegliere a cosa dedicare
il nostro tempo?
Se state pensando
"Se il tempo è così prezioso,
perché gli dedico così poco tempo?",
e vi state immediatamente
chiedendo il perché,
beh, dobbiamo prendere atto
che scegliere è faticoso.
Infatti, richiede uno sforzo cognitivo
che non è necessariamente associato
ad una sensazione di piacere.
E quindi ci affidiamo all'istinto,
che ci offre l'interessante opportunità
di scegliere senza particolare sforzo.
E trascorrono così le nostre giornate.
Ma se, come diceva Aristotele,
"noi siamo quello
che facciamo ripetutamente",
allora scegliere ripetutamente
diventa essenziale,
per il nostro successo
e anche per la nostra felicità.
L'esperienza degli ultimi 15 anni
che ho fatto in Goodyear,
una multinazionale americana
che sposa appieno i valori più nobili
del rispetto per le persone
e per il lavoro,
e che è inevitabilmente legata
alle dinamiche del profitto,
mi ha spinto ad approfondire
proprio questi collegamenti
fra felicità e successo.
Fra tempo investito
e la necessità di scegliere.
In effetti, prendere decisioni
è il vero "core business"
di ogni imprenditore e manager.
In azienda, ad esempio,
per prendere delle decisioni
tra investimenti alternativi,
generalmente calcoliamo
il Return On Investment, o ROI:
una semplice formula matematica
che mette in relazione
l'utile atteso da un investimento
con il capitale
che è necessario investire.
Mi sono allora chiesto:
è possibile calcolare
come impiegare al meglio il nostro tempo?
Diciamo che queste riflessioni
mi hanno così ispirato
il concetto del Return On Work,
o ROW, come l'abbiamo chiamato.
Ne è nata così, per analogia,
un'ipotetica formula matematica
che vuole calcolare
come le risorse e le energie,
il tempo che investiamo
in ogni singola attività
o nella giornata di lavoro,
contribuisce a quello che è un po'
l'obiettivo di tutte le aziende,
ossia la crescita del business.
Ormai da circa un anno mi sono trasferito
in Medio Oriente, a Dubai in particolare -
sempre con Goodyear -
dove i mercati sono
tendenzialmente in crescita,
crisi del petrolio a parte.
Ma ho trascorso tutti gli ultimi anni
di profonda recessione in Sud Europa -
in Portogallo, in Francia,
in Spagna e anche in Italia -
con la necessità di accrescere
il valore del business
in mercati che non crescevano,
con margini in generalizzata contrazione,
e quindi con la necessità
di ridurre costi, di tagliare,
di fare ristrutturazioni.
Inizialmente, insieme al mio team
abbiamo provato a cercare
modalità alternative
per fare di più,
per crescere il valore del business
con minori risorse.
Ma poi abbiamo capito
che questa non era la strada giusta:
fare di più con meno, generalmente,
risulta demotivante per l'organizzazione;
e, a parte i casi
di inefficienze evidenti,
risulta avere anche
un beneficio marginale.
I manager, infatti,
che si trovano costretti
a diluire il loro budget
su una serie di attività
che ritengono importanti,
tendono ad assumere
un comportamento "funzionale",
un comportamento difensivo,
oltre a sentirsi
parte passiva del processo.
Noi invece abbiamo deciso
di fare meno con meno,
ma in modo da generare
un impatto superiore.
Ecco, la vera sfida
è riuscire a capire in team
cosa alla fine farà la differenza
tra il successo e la normalità.
Proprio le riflessioni sul Return On Work
ci hanno fatto mettere in discussione,
partendo dalla formula,
ogni singolo momento,
ogni singola energia profusa
all'interno della giornata lavorativa,
calcolando come questa fosse funzionale
alla crescita del business.
E in caso contrario, l'abbiamo eliminata.
Non vi nascondo che questo approccio
ha avuto un grosso successo
all'interno dell'organizzazione:
ha scatenato un'energia positiva,
un effetto quasi liberatorio.
In effetti, analizzare
le singole attività lavorative,
o le attività che noi facciamo
all'interno di una giornata,
non dal punto di vista
della loro importanza
ma dal punto di vista
della loro essenzialità,
porta a vedere le cose
da un punto di vista
completamente diverso,
e ad essere molto più selettivi
e molto più esigenti,
soprattutto con se stessi.
E a dover scegliere.
Abbiamo così rimesso anche in discussione
il concetto di strategia.
Spesso, nelle aziende,
si confonde la strategia con i numeri,
con il darsi degli obiettivi sfidanti.
Noi invece abbiamo maturato
la consapevolezza
che "strategia" significa dire di "no".
Oggi la vera sfida non è cosa fare:
oggi la vera sfida è cosa eliminare
tra tutto quello
che noi consideriamo importante,
ma che alla fine non farà la differenza.
Attenzione, non si tratta di fare
una lista delle attività
in ordine di importanza.
Si tratta di capire,
tra tutto quello che è importante,
cosa alla fine avrà veramente
un impatto materiale
sui risultati e sull'organizzazione,
e coraggiosamente
eliminare tutto il resto.
Solo così avremo il tempo
per concentrarci su quello
che veramente conta,
e aumentare la nostra
probabilità di successo.
Fare di più, aggiungere,
è relativamente semplice:
fare di meno, eliminare, semplificare,
è molto più complicato.
Perché?
Perché bisogna scegliere.
Discutere in azienda non solo
di numeri, di risultati, di obiettivi,
ma - senza imbarazzi -
anche di altre tematiche
come la felicità, come le energie profuse,
apre gli occhi sull'impatto
che il nostro atteggiamento ha
sull'efficacia dei rapporti.
Proprio le discussioni sul tempo
ci hanno portato a far attenzione
a non occupare inutilmente
il tempo degli altri.
Quante volte ci siamo trovati
in una riunione, in una situazione,
e dopo un po' di tempo abbiamo capito
che stavamo buttando via il nostro tempo?
Be', diciamo che,
soprattutto in azienda,
non è sempre possibile decidere
a cosa dedicare il proprio tempo.
Ma qualcosa la possiamo fare:
possiamo evitare di trascinare colleghi -
ma anche, nella vita privata,
amici, parenti - in situazioni similari.
Ecco, diffondere in Goodyear
il rispetto e la cultura
del valore del tempo altrui
ha raccolto sicuramente
un enorme successo.
Già nel 1958, circa 60 anni fa,
Parkinson con la sua legge postulava:
"Il lavoro si espande
fino ad occupare
tutto il tempo a disposizione".
Più tempo si avrà, più se ne sprecherà.
E quindi abbiamo messo
un po' in discussione
tutto il tempo che trascorrevamo
insieme in azienda.
Abbiamo cominciato con ridurre
le riunioni del 50 percento.
Abbiamo cominciato con eliminare
tutte quelle riunioni
che non erano direttamente collegate
ad una priorità ritenuta essenziale
per la crescita del business.
E poi abbiamo abolito
tutte le presentazioni
più lunghe di una pagina:
quelle lunghe, noiosissime
presentazioni in Power Point
che generalmente hanno lo scopo
di supportare chi presenta -
e, lasciatemi dire, anche
di gratificare chi presenta -
e drenano energia a tutti coloro
che purtroppo sono costretti ad ascoltare.
Così facendo abbiamo liberato
del tempo per la discussione,
e per guardarci negli occhi
e per connettere.
Ecco, la connessione:
guardare una presentazione,
fissare uno schermo,
crea informazione.
Discutere guardandosi negli occhi
crea connessione.
Essere "connessi" significa
avere piena consapevolezza
dei pensieri, delle emozioni
e dello stato d'animo
delle persone che ci sono di fronte.
Solo essendo connessi si riesce
a stabilire una conversazione efficace.
Attenzione, che la vera connessione
richiede impegno!
Sappiamo che ben poco possiamo fare
per migliorare il nostro
quoziente intellettivo,
infatti questo si forma
nei primi anni della nostra vita
ed è in parte congenito;
ma molto possiamo fare
per migliorare quello emotivo
durante tutto l'arco della nostra vita.
Questa è una buona notizia.
Chiaramente bisogna mettere
l'allenamento sull'intelligenza emotiva
in cima alla lista,
e poi bisogna togliersi dal centro.
Bisogna chiedere feedback,
ascoltare senza pregiudizi
e sperimentare.
Ecco, questo è un esercizio
che abbiamo fatto insieme in azienda,
e c'è un antico proverbio che recita:
"Se vuoi andare veloce, rallenta".
Quindi, dedicare
del tempo alla connessione
prima che iniziamo una discussione,
o con una persona o all'interno
di una riunione in azienda,
risulta estremamente efficace,
e ha contribuito a creare
un ambiente di lavoro molto più piacevole.
Ogni nostra parola,
ogni nostro atteggiamento,
ogni nostro sguardo
ha un impatto sulle persone
che sono lì con noi:
avere questa piena consapevolezza
diventa fondamentale
per un utilizzo ottimale del tempo.
Ma fare le scelte giuste
non è ancora abbastanza:
sono le persone
delle quali ci circondiamo,
e soprattutto il contesto che creiamo,
a fare la differenza.
quindi fermarsi un attimo
per riflettere su questi argomenti
diventa necessario.
Diventa necessario proprio per evitare
di trascorrere le nostre giornate,
come dicevo all'inizio,
"rincorrendo affannosamente",
e per restare lucidi.
Solo restando lucidi si riesce
ad essere efficaci:
con noi stessi,
ma soprattutto con gli altri.
Ecco: è la lucidità l'ingrediente segreto
senza il quale la formula
del Return On Work non torna.
E quindi, è importante fermarsi
per ricordarsi di respirare -
e dedicare del tempo
a noi stessi e agli altri
come vero stile di vita e di business.
e ammirare tutta la bellezza
che ogni giorno appare ai nostri occhi,
e respirare anche i profumi più delicati.
Le persone di successo stanno bene
perché si regalano del tempo
e lo donano agli altri.
Sono le persone per le quali
il cuore batte per una ragione vera!
È la "leadership del dare", oggi,
quella che permette la perfetta sintonia
tra felicità e successo.
Donare le nostre risorse
più preziose agli altri
è come donarle alla nostra felicità.
D'altronde, sappiamo bene che l'altruismo
è la prima forma di egoismo.
Ma come facciamo a restare lucidi
se la cultura umana ci porta a pensare
che per fare bene, per avere successo,
bisogna fare di più?
Il Return On Work
mi ha aiutato a scegliere,
e a trovare il tempo da dedicare a me
e da dedicare agli altri.
E la sera, quando torno a casa
e appoggio la testa sul cuscino,
rivedo tutti i fotogrammi della giornata
e tutti quei momenti
in cui sono riuscito
a respirare, e a connettere,
e a dedicare il mio tempo agli altri.
Penso che la bellezza della vita
stia nel dare e nel condividere,
e mi addormento felice.
Ecco, per chiudere questo momento,
non posso che augurarvi tempo.
Non un dono qualunque,
come scriveva Eli Michler
in una sua poesia.
Tempo non solo per trascorrerlo,
ma perché ve ne resti.
Tempo non solo per guardare l'orologio,
ma per toccare le stelle.
Tempo per trovare voi stessi;
tempo per la vita.
Grazie per il tempo
che oggi avete deciso di donarmi.
(Applausi)